hey everyone how's it going my name's
Mei Yuko and welcome to my channel where
we talk about tech career and life so I
graduated from UC San Diego in 2014 with
a bachelor's in computer science now I
know it's been a minute since I've been
in college and I know that college life
in 2020 looks drastically different from
every year prior now that I've been out
of college for a while I've had some
time to reflect on what are the things
that I did during school that helped me
in the long run so today I'm gonna share
some of my sage advice for the next
generation of CS majors so keep on
watching I want to take a moment to say
thank you to our sponsor for this video
good wall good wall is a next generation
social platform that enables students
and professionals to become better
together this app is honestly a great
one-stop-shop for being able to showcase
the work that you're proud of as well as
finding a community of people with
similar interests and find scholarships
and jobs and it's especially good for
people who are looking to broaden their
network and their horizons past their
school their workplace and their
geographic area I do really think that
it's cool that you can show your
achievements and also talk about the
skills that you've learned along the way
so download the good wall app on iOS or
Android and create a profile for
absolutely free by clicking my link in
the description box down below I'm
actually hosting a Q&A session in this
app so tap on messages channels and look
for myuca Q&A where I'll be answering
any questions that you have over the
next week good wall thank you for
sponsoring and let's get back to the
video so my life in college was not a
cakewalk by any means in fact it was one
of the most challenging times of my life
so during college I was a computer
science major didn't minor in anything I
worked part time the whole way through
to feed myself and pay for my expenses I
also was really active in to student
organizations of which both became vice
president for eventually I lived off
campus for the majority of my undergrad
and it took me a little over four years
to complete my degree I'm grateful for
the opportunity to have gone and
graduated from college and I know that
it's made me a better person
and has afforded me more opportunities
as a result anyways a lot of people talk
about the college triangle which is
between social life and good grades and
good health you can only choose to
actually think it's really possible to
do all three in fact all of my tips
touch on one part of the triangle and
also talk about the triangle a little
bit more at the end of the video but
yeah let's do some advice so here's my
advice on how to have a more fruitful
balanced and meaningful college
experience as a CS major so something
that they don't tell you about life
after college is that college is
literally one of the best times to meet
new people and widen your network and
that opportunities like this are really
hard to come by afterwards I think many
wonderful things come together to make
colleges magical place to meet new
people for one thing there are a bunch
of people around you who are roughly the
same age as you it's also really easy to
find people who share your interests
through school activities people who are
your major are sitting next to you every
single day in class tough classes create
a sense of community and camaraderie
between you and random people and y'all
all live in like a five-mile radius of
one another so it's really easy to
create and maintain friendships so you
got a network in college and this is for
a couple of reasons
for one college is a great time to
establish those lifelong friendships and
it's a great chance to make connections
with people who are going to be in your
industry so join some student
organizations and areas that are
interesting to you you don't have to
join just the computer science club
there's also acapella or yoga or a
cultural Club it's a great time to
explore your hobbies and find people to
do them with and make friends in class I
was actually always too shy to make
friends in my class because the imposter
syndrome would get to me because I'm
comparing myself to another person but
it's one of my biggest regrets about
College because those friends will help
you get through a tough class together
and it's more fun to code with friends
than coding alone all the time and
lastly make friends with upper-class men
people upper-class people who are older
than you they can warn you about what
classes are hard what professors to take
what programming assignments are hard or
easy seriously trust their advice and
their experiences you'll be glad that
you did and once they graduate they're
gonna get jobs and when you need that
internship or full-time role they can be
a great resource and help you out so
yeah network now as I've talked about in
my CS degree video I didn't really have
like the best grades so I'm probably not
the best person to give you academic
advice but I was able to find
internships throughout college and find
a full time role pretty quickly and I
think what helped me to do this is to
have a general plan what I mean by this
is to have a plan for both your
academics
and what you want to be doing after
college I knew that my goal after
college was to be financially stable and
independent so a lot of what I did
during college was to help me achieve
that goal so make sure to ask yourself
what is it that you want to be doing
after college and what do you have to do
right now to get there academically
speaking having a plan helps you to be
more realistic about the coursework that
you have see as coursework in my
experience always takes way longer than
you think between programming
assignments midterms quizzes other
projects and finals these days now that
I'm out of college whenever I met with
an immense amount of work I sit down and
kind of plan what I need to do over the
next month I break large tasks into
small achievable chunks so that it
doesn't feel overwhelming anymore and I
know what I need to do to get from point
A to point B I think I might have gotten
better grades if I actually did this
during college and I know having a plan
can feel really overwhelming it can
start to define you and every failure
can feel like you're not making any
progress this is where I think it's
really important to have some balance
and to remember that your college
experience and your major does not fully
define who you are
school is just one part of your journey
so make the best of it
make a plan but don't lose yourself in
the process
and speaking of balance one of the
things that I did that really improved
my quality of life during and after
graduation was to take care of
I mean let's face it like majoring in CS
is really intense think of all like the
coursework the time in the labs the
all-nighters the stress that you feel
from tests and programming assignments
in addition to any existing commitments
that you might already have like a job
or a family but if you take some time
and take care of your body it'll perform
much better and feel much better during
this time of stress
so getting to seven to nine hours of
sleep every night really did it for me
it allowed me to stay awake in class and
actually learn stuff as well as just
stay more alert during the day so that
I'm using my best brain for everything
big braids we need the big brain eating
as healthy as you can is also really
important I say as healthy as you can
because I don't what it's like to be
really poor during college and I know
the cup noodles is like the most
economical choice but hear me out if you
think about food as fuel for our bodies
to create energy if you put in good fuel
into your bodies it creates good energy
to help you tackle whatever make up and
lastly take care of your mental health
like I said again and again college is
stressful when I was in college I used
to suppress and bury a lot of emotions
when really the better and healthier
thing to do is to let them out and
process those feelings in a safe way so
go to therapy meditate take your
medication do whatever you got to do to
feel like yourself so as far as the
college triangle goes I think the key is
to have a better balance between the
three like for instance maybe try making
your triangle a little bit smaller than
you'd expect as in do your main two
things a little bit less to make room
for the third thing and have realistic
expectations of what it would take to
attain all three I mean I don't really
think that there is like a perfect
college experience College is literally
what you make of it and every person
will have a very different experience
based on their personality limits and
strengths but make sure to take some
time to reflect and figure out what you
need to grow towards the person that you
want to be and achieve your goals
I think that's the best that we can do
sometimes so make sure to be realistic
and kind to yourself in the end I think
it's about setting boundaries and doing
what you have to do during those short
four to five years make the best of it
and be bold in protecting your time
anyway that's it for this video I hope
you enjoyed it and if you did consider
subscribing my social links are also all
in description box down below and I will
see you next time bye